dr taran narula is a cardiologist at
lennox hill hospital
northwell health here in new york city
and she joins us now dr narula good
morning to you good morning
so so far this has affected people 30
and younger
who have had the pfizer or the moderna
vaccine
what more do we know at this point well
tony we've been seeing this signal of a
potential link between the mrna vaccines
fiasco moderna and myocarditis both here
and abroad for several months
and yesterday's advisory committee
really said that yes there is likely an
association there but as nikki said in
the piece the risk is very small
we're talking about almost 400 confirmed
cases
when you look at the characteristics of
who it's affecting it tends to be males
younger than 30 usually after the second
dose of the vaccine with symptoms
occurring within about a week
most common symptom is chest pain and we
don't really understand the mechanism
behind this myocarditis yet
obviously we're gonna have to follow
these patients long term but the key
point again that nikki made is that
acutely the prognosis seems very good
these patients have really
a mild course of illness get discharged
quickly so the cdc says that eligible
children should still get vaccinated but
parents are obviously hesitant what
would you say to those parents
well there's going to be a lot of
conversations at doctor's offices for
sure but again
both the advisory committee yesterday
and over a dozen public health
organizations and societies published a
statement saying that at this point
the benefit still outweighs the risk and
why is that well when you look at the
beginning of the pandemic we've had over
2000 deaths in those under 30 from covid
4 000 cases of misty we know about post
coveted symptoms
individuals who get covid can also
develop myocarditis so
it's really key to kind of weigh that
and really at this point
the scale tips towards the side of
benefits still for those over 12.
all right the math is clear dr taran
arula thank you very much we appreciate
it
thank you